[Music]
we are at the warner brothers lot
you may not know that watching at home
and uh but the warner brothers lot where
we tape is a great place to be for the
holidays and i'll tell you why
warner brothers they've been around
forever
they have this amazing library of
amazing incredible tv shows stuff that
goes way back they have rare directors
cuts
of all the holiday shows we grew up
watching
on television stuff you've never seen
before i want to show you this check out
this footage that was cut from the
original rankin and bass 1970 classic
santa claus
is coming to town they took this scene
out but we found it
there's all kinds of ways we can help
each other you can bring me nice new
toys and
i can assist you with my magic how oh
i'll show you
gaze into my magic crystal snowball
someone
is looking for you
[Applause]
[Music]
i look a lot like that guy
oh you the santa guy you mean yeah yeah
the puppet right everyone understood
what i was talking about
but maybe you meant the dude on that
that's me in a moment of ecstasy right
there
that's me
that's me in a moment of passion
it's the suit i wear and everything